You do what? You Ping Pong? Hate off of
one another. Yeah, unless it's funny.
It can be funny sometimes funny.
Sometimes he hey, good. Hey, funny.
It's just between yourselves.
It's like Patrice. Patrice was,
it was one of the best, one of
the best funny haters. Okay.
You okay? You, you bring up a good
point. Comedic hate is a different guy.
A different kind of hate. Yeah.
Communicate Right. [inaudible] in peace.
One of the, not one of the, probably the
best Patrice. Patrice [inaudible] time.
I remember when I would talk and if I was
saying something to you would just here
now, what would you tell him
about? He's like, Ugh, what?
What are you talking about?
He's like, just the way you talk
voice, everything about your voice just
makes me want to punch you in the face.
We talking about here.
Go after you to,
it's kind of made you feel good too.
Like if you're a comment specially
if you're a comic, like a,
I called opie and Anthony once I
was talking to them and Anthony.
Anthony always has a gun on him.
He carries a gun everywhere.
Like he has a concealed carry permit
and shit. And I said to him, I said,
do you ever worry that maybe you're
putting out this energy and you're
manifesting something like some
sort of an attack on you? Yeah.
Because you're constantly dwelling on
it and you always have this gun and
Patrice goes, Joe, believe in
magic. Believe me. Conjuring up to where,
hey man, a positive relative just
starts laughing at sea. He is mad.
And I'm like,
when he would go after you mad,
it's like you just want
to step back and watch.
I remember he got bill burrs so mad on
time. Oh bill used to get so fucking mad.
Beautiful thing about bill burble.
We'd be snap it.
Bill bill was got to get my bag here.
Funny if you went up to him.
None of it's funny.
You're laughing. Can you build
like where's the punchline in it?
There's no punchline. He is so
fucking mad. We the comedy cellar,
the days that we had their man Bill
Berber trees on nail, Keith Robinson,
Jim Norton, Collin Quinn, myself. Um,
when I say we would sit at this table,
we sit at this table for four to five
hours and it will be nothing but beautiful
trash bins to one another.
When I say they used to
give me so much shit,
that's probably why it's
so hard to bother me.
Mouth the trashcans that I took from
the age 20 to 24 and my young comedic
career about how awful I was.
I had a joke,
I had a joke way at the beginning
of my career because at a time,
let me preface this,
this was way in the beginning of my
career was a joke that I had about uh,
about a little people midgets
at the time and it's, you know,
it was so bad.
She was,
I got robbed by cross side Niche and the
joke was I didn't know he was robbing
me cause I was with somebody else.
So he was looking at my
friend but he was robbing me.
It was like a play on being
crowd was very, very awful joke.
I remember telling this joke and a
phone book comes flying on the state,
put trace through a fucking
phone book at me. I'm talking,
this is the where the Boston comedy club,
people in the crowd, tiny little place.
All you heard was,
and you sit back,
it hits the floor. And I say, Yo, what
the fuck was that? And Patrice said,
read it is better material in
it than what you're saying now.
Crawls does laughing. He's Ugh. They all,
they used to trash me
so bad. So bad man. Uh,
d your legendary Patrice of news story,
a corporate trees jerking
off at my house before
I moved to La. I'm staying in the two
bedroom apartment. I had just got there.
Patrice was coming out. I said, Yo,
you need play Sas. I got two bedrooms.
You can come there. It's my ex wife at
the time. Uh, you know, I come home,
it's like afternoon, like
Patrice. I'm like, Yo,
you haul but traced,
portrays.
I go out in the back, open up the
door. I said, as big as computer
Paul,
all I see is his back hunched over like,
like,
it's like baby oil. Right?
And I come in, I'm like, Yo,
what you doing? He's like, Yo,
get out. Get Out. Get Out.
You're jerking off at my house.
He's so sick. He's so fucking sick. Daddy.
He didn't stop.
He was so concerned with finishing
that he didn't even break stride.
He didn't turn around. If we nothing you
get out. Can you just saw his back hunch?
He came out like seven minutes later.
It was like my bed.
I ain't know you was coming home.
Did
I fucking Patrice Man, I love him
to death. Love him to death. Yeah.
He had the most, don't give a fuck
of any comic I ever met. 100%.
Most 100%. Good and bad
though. You know, there was,
there was a good to it and there
was also some bad to, you know,
a lot of things that didn't have been
for Patrice probably could have happened,
but I think the level of
not giving a fuck, uh,
prevented some of those days where
he was almost two authentic. Yes.
Like his like GMC. That
was it. Charlie Sheen's
rose who's roast was it that he did where
he just torching everybody else that
was on the rose window and then he got
up there and after he signed he saw the
fuckers on my level.
Why am I here?
What you guys, who the fuck
is this man? Who's this bitch?
Oh my God. Patrice has so many of those
things. Yeah. So many things. One of,
one of the best to do it. Uh,
if you, if you are listening in,
I educated at one Patrice on,
yeah,
just I asked did you just
watch a elephant in the room?
One of his specialists, some of that,
some of the funniest shit ever, man.
And so insightful. He was so
wide, very business smart.
The way people thought and
behaved would say shit.
Like one of the things that he said
that I tell people all the time, it's a,
it's a brilliant thing that he said it
was, um, I forget what controversy it was,
but he was on television with some woman
who was saying that you should never
tell jokes about certain
things, you know, and they were,
they were getting mad at someone,
I think it was opie and Anthony
about a joke and he said,
you got to understand that all
jokes come from the same place,
the ones you like and the ones you don't
like, the ones they make you laugh.
And the ones that make you mad,
they all come from the same place.
Someone's just trying to be funny. Yeah.
Like sometimes they just don't work.
I, I had a talk, I had
a talk with the, the,
I forgot her name,
but it was when I was doing all the promo
of upside and I kept trying to break
down, you know, where, where,
where the jokes come from.
You know, Kevin, these uh,
insensitive jokes that you told
back then why? What makes you,
why would you even say those things?
And the hardest thing for me to explain,
I was like,
do you think people think of jokes and
while thinking of them think that they're
not going to be funny?
Everything that you
think of in a joke form,
you're thinking of it because you think
you're going to get a laugh behind it.
Yeah. The gamble is if I get
the lab versus not get the lab,
you don't get the laugh.
The joke was not funny.
If I get a laugh and I
guess I'm on to something,
there isn't a bunch of thought that goes
into the funny moments that we think
may be great bits.
Yeah.
I wish that I had a more logical answer
to put behind it. I said, well, I don't,
especially at that time, my career,
I just thought it would be funny.
The same way that some people thinks
are jokes funded offer. It's a thought.
Comedians are constantly
throwing shit out there. Yeah.
You're constantly rolling a dice
shit out there. Had the shits.
You role and good. Right. It's not
going to be good. The other half,
maybe all right,
may be kind of good,
but it's all with the intent
of entertaining is not
what the intent of being
malicious is.
Not what the intent of sparking hatred
is all trying to make you laugh.
Yeah. That's it. Like it's,
it's literally that simple from a
thought within a comedian's mind.
Yeah. Nothing, nothing else. And
they kept trying to look for this,
like a hard definition of why.
And I was like,
I don't have it.
I don't have the reason why
I thought it would be funny.
And it wasn't.
That's the downfall.